he is known in John Barry how are you
John hello rich first off I'd like to
thank you for making the combine so much
money you know John I'm finally I have
finally begin to feel somewhat close to
normal
moving around isn't as difficult you
know I did I did kind of pull something
in my final training session five days
before the run that reared its ugly head
on the 22 yard line of my first of three
runs but you know I I have heart I can't
teach that John and I only know one
stayed quite frankly yeah well that's me
I mean it was so slow I could hear
Chariots of Fire playing in the back
charge the fire was about very fast
Brits man come on now that's all I've
got
that's my only option so I'm snooping
off take the tie off but just that's not
the same thing you know time go bow tie
yes suggested I mean I I'd like to see
Charles Barkley and dick Bavetta out
there with you I don't know what the
all-star game years ago I think I am
going to win that one should that one
happen so oh god take you I would take
you when's the last time you ran a
40-yard dash John oh-ho
seriously Wow I retired and o6o I've not
exerted myself in at least 13 years but
they've never they never let me in
whatever testing that was required of
you prior to the NBA though they'll make
you run distances do they did you mean
no no no forties I think like if you
worked out 40 maybe do a shuttle run or
so you go that but you know nothing more
than running the court suicides eat
suicides something like that suicides
suicides that's right okay it seems to
me like you probably ran a few of those
in your day what so here's here's the
grand opening question for you
basketball-wise John what is wrong with
the Lakers what went wrong with the
Lakers this year well I I mean it's
funny how people are so surprised of
what's going on
I mean this clearly wasn't a roster that
was built around LeBron James he showed
up late in the proceedings basically
that they couldn't go do anything else
didn't have much cap space to do much I
mean they bring in Rondo Stephenson
Beasley JaVale McGee a resigned
caldwell-pope I mean those are really
players that aren't built around LeBron
to be good around LeBron James so you
lose LeBron for whatever was 18 games I
think there were six and 12 they had a
really good run before that Lanza went
down he started he was starting to play
very well so it was close but again I'm
not totally surprised because I didn't
think this had the makeup of being a
team that we're really gonna compare
well I think the surprise if I can give
voice to those who are surprised by this
is that clearly there's no Kevin Love on
this roster but you want to talk about
talented people I mean Kuzma is Ingram
his ball is when he can actually stay
out there on the floor I mean when you
came into the season obviously they were
they were lacking shooters on the
perimeter which a lot of people are
surprised they didn't sign Brook Lopez
and instead did what they did otherwise
Beasley being one and you know Tyson
Chandler once they could try and get him
when the season began that this rosters
not that much worse than the the Cavs
team he took to the finals last year is
it no no it's more talented there's no
question but the title of talent is you
have to have around LeBron James the
number one trait that you have to have
is to be able to shoot the ball being a
standstill shooter a guy that doesn't
want to handle the ball so let's go
through those players Lonzo ball what's
his greatest weakness shooting the
basketball Brandon Ingram is not a
3-point shooter he's a guy that needs to
pound the ball he's a he's terrific by
the way I think he's most improved on
this team but he needs to pound it he's
a mid-range guy Kuzma surprisingly not
shooting the three-ball well at all he
should be a decent shooter but he's
around 30%
Rondo doesn't shoot it Stephenson not a
three-point shooter so again the makeup
around the team those guys are very
talented guys don't get me wrong but
they don't fit the skillset that you
need around the bra James okay do you
think LeBrons checked out I'm hearing
that a lot locally here in Los Angeles
obviously the news that he's gonna be on
a minute's limit and on back-to-backs
he's either not playing the the first or
the second game d are you of the mindset
watching him hit the backboard on an
inbounds pass etc etc that he's checked
out John well I think there's great
frustration but when you like to be
checked out averaging 27 9 boards that's
a pretty good check out so the numbers
are still there obviously but yeah I see
a lot of frustration a lot of looking
over at the bench a lot of just you know
terrible body language out on the floor
you mentioned that that throw-in that
hit the bottom of the board the other
day the ball rolling up the court he's
done that a couple times and just kicked
it out of bounds the other day and he's
frustrated there's no question about it
but again I can't imagine that he's that
surprised based on what kind of talent
they're the people they have around him
that that this is going on and as far as
shutting it down I'm really not for it I
understand for the future I wouldn't
want to put any more miles on this guy
but you signed a contract
people are buying tickets to come watch
you play and what are we gonna do every
superstar player that's on a team that
doesn't make the playoffs we're just
gonna shut him down is that is that what
we do now well I agree you know and and
you know you take a look at some of the
back-to-back somebody's gonna be very
disappointed that number 23 is not not
suiting up so I guess I just put a bow
on on the Lakers conversation here
before you hit the Celtics John what's
the answer because Anthony Davis it's
gonna require a lot to acquire clearly
and who else could come that could
actually work out and you got the
Clippers also performing as well as they
have been performing
they've got Jerry West putting a very
nice team together for Doc with Doc I
mean they've got a Los Angeles welcome
mat open as well we know the Knicks are
gonna be competitive and they've put all
their eggs in that porzingis trade
basket for two max contracts what's the
answer for the law that's just a couple
of teams here what's the answer for the
Lakers do you think yeah I think there's
a lot of work to be done you know
obviously these veteran players they
know they're not part of the future
these young guys got a taste of the NBA
business of having their names in the
trade talks that did the Lakers really
think that they're a part of the future
that they're questioning that obviously
it's a fragmented group right now so a
lot of a lot of questions
who's gonna come I don't think Hawaii
comes I don't think Kevin Durant comes
could could Kyrie Irving come back under
the wings and LeBron James because
clearly he's not very happy in Boston
being the number one guy with cameras in
his face as he walks into arena
I mean god forbid you get paid thirty
million dollars in a camera gets in your
face so I don't you know there's a ton
of work to be done for the LA Lakers and
it really it's a domino effect when we
get into this you know free agency July
1st who goes where and we'll see where
the pieces fall all right John Barry
here on the Rich Eisen show ESPN radio
coming up on Saturday night you can also
catch Boston at Lakers on ABC let's talk
about Kyrie you had an interesting
comment there about Kyrie and his
statements about the business of the NBA
and him not really liking it very much
obviously you didn't take too kindly to
that from what I heard well I mean you
have to deal with that I mean you left
LeBron James you left the championship
team and you wanted your own team that
that's what comes with it and I don't
you know it's just surprising that
there's any surprise about that with
them or that that's the way it is and
you know what you getting paid a lot of
money and you have a very talented group
and to be unhappy is just surprising to
me so that was a hell of a
Wainwright apparently from Boston all
the way to the west coast they say that
that that helped right the ship and then
obviously what they did in Golden State
handing the team the worst loss in the
car era and then - Kyrie getting another
performance from Gordon Hayward that
certainly heartens
the Celtics fans do you think that they
have in fact turned the corner John well
I mean you know it's a couple of games
we've seen them play great throughout
the season you know fortunately they did
back it up in Sacramento after that
great win at Golden State with no Kyrie
so we'll see if they can maintain that
focus but I think the bottom line is
everybody agrees that this is the most
talented team in the Eastern Conference
now I know Milwaukee's playing great
Toronto as well Philadelphia but I think
if this team does did it right which it
appears that maybe that's going to
happen that this is still the team to
beat regardless of what seed they get so
give me your best guess as to what
happened on that plane unless you
already do know I mean it's somebody
who's well I don't know a lot of planes
and a lot of teams that can bond at odd
situations or if plane is not an odd
situation I mean what do you think
happen on that point John well I had the
Boston warrior game Tuesday and a Brad
Stevens said that he and Kai Reed talked
it was not like a big meeting I mean
that's just kind of a regular plane ride
where a lot of times a coach will bring
up numerous players one player whatever
they had a conversation but you know
it's just about this whole group and the
way they played that night you know as -
klay Thompson mind you and the Warriors
sometimes are disinterested in the
regular season but they had a
season-high an assist they'd just played
enthusiastic the guys were up on the
bench they were the camaraderie was was
with what it needs to be and if these
guys do do that I mean this is the best
team I mean they went to the finals lat
you know Eastern finals last year
without Kyrie and how a work now hey
what's playing well his career is
healthy he's a terrific player and they
have a great opportunity to go to the
finals account did Brad share share with
you anything that you could share with
us about what they said to each other oh
no really
no I really didn't I mean it's just
normal talk and
you know a lot of comments that the
kairi's made in the media of just this
has not been you know leadership quality
comments and maybe talked him about that
I don't know but again he's got him he's
got to embrace the situation that he's
in and he's going to get the attention
and you just got to handle it better and
quite frankly be a better leader John
Barry here on the Rich Eisen show a
couple more minutes left with him
so obviously the NBA is not as much of a
knee-jerk league as the NFL because they
don't play one game a week that said
there's always something that does
happen like that game that you said you
were at in Oakland between the Celtics
and the Warriors where narratives can
form and I'm wondering if it's real or
not and that is coming on that game that
boogy Cousins is a potential defensive
liability that they still haven't
figured it out yet how to work him in
and that he's another guy along with Dre
mom that can be easily triggered during
the playoffs at an inopportune time is
that a viable narrative to come out of
that game that night John well yeah I
mean he's been getting attacked cousins
defense atleast no doubt about it and
any real close game he's been on the
bench in the last three four or five
minutes because of that and Steve Kerr
knows that he's going to go to his best
defensive unit it's usually the smaller
group with Iguodala out there so know
now you bring in Bogut was a terrific
defensive player we'll see how much he
gets an opportunity there but DeMarcus
Cousins knew this summer when he signed
he was told we're going after a
championship there might be times when
you're not on the floor at the end of
ballgames are you okay with that
and it's a rhetorical question because
they don't care if he's okay with it or
not I'm gonna do what they need to do to
win a championship right you know Steve
Kerr is gonna he's gonna do what he has
to do so you know depending on matchups
you know particularly the Houston
Rockets who by the way are really hot
right now it's scary you wouldn't see
DeMarcus Cousins on the floor very often
against that team they don't play big
against them so he's gonna have to
embrace and get ready for that as well
not being on the floor pot possibly in
close games
so here I am thinking July 1 the season
really comes down to what happens on
July 1 because we're assuming the
Warriors have another parade are you
telling me somebody's ready to beat them
in a seven-game series John boundaries
that were you telling well I'm telling
you that the Houston the Houston Rockets
are scary they're beaten Golden State's
three straight times this year they play
them next week I believe on the 14th in
Houston that will be a very interesting
game I want to see if Golden State goes
after that game to send a message
because Houston has no fear and remember
Chris Paul if he doesn't sprain/strain
is a groin or hamstring last year maybe
they win that 7th game in the Houston
hosting the trophy John Barry always
enjoy our chats I got to get you in next
time you're in Los Angeles John I can't
have these phone calls while you're in
the valley
I can't make that drive I mean it's just
this is the LA traffic's too much for me
John you don't have the kobe helicopter
at your disposal is that your time I
could call you know I should have called
them you know we could send you a car
John I mean we can do these we do this
all requiring you to drive yourself come
on John well no I'd love to see the
studio though absolutely okay we'll get
it done I would say during the Laker
playoff run but the Clipper playoff run
John how about the Clipper playoff run
don't sleep on the Clippers man come on
now well they better they better get out
of the 8th spot or it's not going to be
a very long run John I look forward to
your call this weekend and we'll chat
again soon thanks for the con words on
the combine
you got it rich you go that's John Barry
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience